the avian Adult Entertainment Expo was
in Las Vegas and we the future of sex is
here we got a bunch of things we're
gonna show you this may be slightly NSFW
depending on where you work so you are
warned let's look at the real sex dolls
so yes these are lifelike imitations of
women those are I mean that's human
sized and they are squishy and you can
put them in all kinds of positions they
cost about $8,500 a pop and you can get
a lifelike rendering of a famous porn
star and for a little extra if you're
willing to pay a little bit more you can
get a lifelike rendering of any one you
like that seems really kind of sick like
well the person know is this just can
you take a picture of someone on the
street yeah so let's just start talking
about those because I do think this type
of thing is the future I mean those
things they'll eventually connect them
to the Internet you know you're your
partner or anonymous person will be on
the other end controlling the doll
you'll be sitting at home you'll have
something attached to your Wang I mean
is this we can't stop it it's like the
iPhone story it's like like no this
can't be something that keeps being
updated with like a new system the 7
whatever it can't be like not only is
this like I just picture a bunch of like
world of work I have to get and I'm
sorry not on the continent yeah I mean
the thing is like I am all about gamers
and people that sit home and do whatever
but it's just like I just pictured some
creepy like you know dormant people just
with their doll like having full
relationships and conversations also I
would like to mention what I don't like
about this is if you can get anybody
made made essentially I mean this is
opening on a serious level this is
opening up a world of trouble for
pedophiles you know of stalkers like
very weird extreme
yeah it's getting very weird and I don't
like it
is some of this though this is just how
it works so related to our iPhone
conversation in our facebook covers that
these things just come
and people and especially you know with
porn and sex related things they often
lead the technology which is why VHS
beat Veda and you know DVDs and etc etc
traditionally the male has never thought
in terms of you know I need a toy but it
scares the male subconsciously to think
that toy after toy to the sigh bein to
the whatever we're it's the rise of the
Machine and soon will be replaced
because if you know you go to the sex
shop and you see one of these gigantic
vibrators right as this I have a mere
human penis look at what they've given
me to work with I can't compete with
that and that that if the person who was
using that adjusts to wow this is
infinitely better and I no longer lead
the you know the electrical spark of
another human touching me we're gone no
one wants to put up with this whiny
petulant support system to run this one
thing that they got the better version
of yeah and we're already see it's so
large that it's kind of hard to hide
it's not like like if the family comes
over for dinner you're like put a
lampshade you know it's very Christmas
story but like to the next level if you
have the $8,500 to drop on this thing
I'm guessing you might have enough money
for like an extra room so you're like
what's nice is like where's that money I
got a dollar
rub not gonna make that into an office
for centers the one-percenters it can be
having sex with robots at us poor B
we're having sex with humans like a
bunch of Schmucks and speaking of that
let's move on so there's a lot more
stuff we got for you here do you know
what bronies are this is people that
have a fascination with my little pony
and you can get a butt plug to have a
tail like a My Little Pony let's take a
look yeah so that glass part that's
gonna go in the in the but there I guess
that works for a woman or a man and I
believe well there you go
and then you know she can put on little
ears and just become a my little
poni thing look you know everybody has
their things that get them off and
different things that they're into and
all that this type of thing seems
particularly strange to me and I say
that without judgment I just saying I'm
not into the pony thing I would like to
comment on the fact how exactly did this
come to be like a collective term like I
can't imagine the conversation that was
said it was like bro are you going to
pump my little pony yeah dude totally
yeah Rory's mom I guess at what point
was that like a bro conversation that
actually like made you have like this
much use my moment of like liking things
in the butt and liking my little ponies
like that those two things don't seem
very like when people are doing these
these things that are a little out of
the norm
I sort of admire them in a weird way
that they could be so like okay with
everything that'd be like yeah I'm gonna
have my I'm gonna put the pony thing up
there and do it like isn't there
something freeing about those people oh
yeah it speaks to the American
entrepreneurial spirit yeah sure some
fellow over there trying to invent a
perpetual motion generator and another
one over here trying to scribble down
some device that sucks in all the
pollution and blows out pure oxygen but
not the true entrepreneurial spirit no
sir and then you'll market it on
Facebook and on Twitter yeah yeah well
speaking of entrepreneurial spirit let's
look at the magic ball so the magic ball
is sort of like you know a bouncy
exercise ball and it appears comes in
blue and pink which delineates the sex
for you and there's big penis on the
bouncing ball now we've talked a lot
about you know Fitness and things and
you know these balls are actually very
healthy for you Anna who works here at
the young Kirk she sits on okay that's
gonna sound really no no not one of
those balls I don't think those she has
a regular ball but as far as I know it's
a regular ball I'm gonna get in a lot of
trouble for that the point is this seems
like something that might be appeal to
people don't you think
you know I like to kill two birds with
one stone and this seems like I'm
getting my fitness and my freak on at
the same time I also feel like someone
is going to lose an eye
you know entry into another orifice they
don't want with this I don't know like I
mean I guess I need to try one out and
see like what level of bounce we're
getting here because like are we talking
like just a slight moment or am I gonna
get like impaled you know and like get
my jugular polka I don't know it seems
like it can be a crapshoot yeah I don't
know if they come in different sizes or
anything like that but to bring this
whole episode fully around and in a full
circle let's look at the [ __ ] pipe the
[ __ ] pipe so the pipe goes on the penis
and then you can smoke a ball and then I
guess smoke a [ __ ] and we started with
weed and President Obama and now we're
finishing up with the white men shave -
now you're a huge fire hazard - yeah
that's not the way I'm going out I'm not
going out like that that would be
terrible your whole Bush and a little
too long did penises shrink like
dramatically since I've been what I do
because why isn't on the tip of her
finger and she's smoking it I'm confused
is it like an elastic band like a [ __ ]
ring or is it just for incredibly small
men Whitney I appreciate your lesbian
questions according to the website a
cockpit a cockpit according to the
website a [ __ ] pipe quote combines a
molded smoking pipe that is embedded
within a circular silicone sleeve for
external placement on the shaft of a
user's penis for promoting and enhancing
erectile function while another user or
multiple users that's the key orally
enjoy the use of a molded smoking pipe
so yes you've explained it I see so
basically what you're saying is the sex
industry is really trying to cut down
time for everyone they've created this
ball that you can exercise on they've
created this pipe where you can get high
and
and and smoke pipe they've created that
that that Lube fountain which is
essentially like fondue for swingers
clubs I think you know we didn't post
that one but we'll put the link to the
article there is a Lube literally a Lube
fountain it looks like a Golden Corral
like chocolate thing and it's Lube that
you can just that's the one you want to
drunkenly knock over and watch the gap
the comics slip and slide sequence with
all the people good for the sex industry
for really cutting down time
yeah I'm really having sex yeah that's
everything except people exactly you
don't need to take them out on a date
what have sex with one person a furry
Bush 70s porn guy
[Music]